el desalojo empezó en la madrugada de
este martes según la organización sin
ánimo de lucro francia tierra de asilo
en este campamento irregular en sant
dennis al norte de parís había al menos
2.400 refugiados las autoridades dicen
que estos albergues no se pueden
permitir seco estos campos no son
aceptables en parte por las personas que
se encuentran en situación de miseria y
hay que decir también que hay
situaciones de delincuencia que imponen
verdaderas dificultades para los vecinos
y es absolutamente necesario que estos
campos puedan ser tratados y sobre todo
que no sean reconstruidos constituye
pero no es la primera vez que las
organizaciones defensoras de migrantes
ven escenas como estas si siete la
comida fue si ésta fuera la primera vez
podríamos pensar que sólo un accidente
de la forma como las autoridades
francesas reciben a los migrantes que no
lo vieron venir que llegó como una
sorpresa pero son cerca de 70
evacuaciones y cada vez es lo mismo ya
sabemos qué pasa después
la policía añadió que actúa en línea con
la directriz del ministerio del interior
para ofrecer un refugio digno a las
personas en situaciones
e identificar aquellas que no tienen sus
papeles al día pero hay organizaciones
que dicen que aquí no se está
resolviendo el problema y la solución
sería que francia implementará la ley de
asilo porque las personas aquí son
solicitantes del recurso en sus países
estas personas están siendo perseguidas
amenazadas por la guerra aquí por
ejemplo hay muchos afganos hay somalíes
sudaneses sólo países en guerra de donde
las personas huyen y vienen aquí para
pedir asilo
en la mañana de este martes cientos de
personas se aglomeraron para subirse a
los buses que los llevarían a otros
campamentos pero varias horas después
todavía había muchos esperando su turno
al menos una treintena de organizaciones
temen que esta no será la última vez que
verán esta escena